hello oh look at you is so pathetic
[Music]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to SCP unity they've
finally updated the game and in updating
the game they've updated the monsters
the environment the way the map is laid
out and the new spooks that lay inside
of it this update has been a long time
coming it's been almost half a year
since I played the last version of this
and it was quite buggy when it happened
but now SCP unity is back so it's best
to go back to the beginning my name is d
mark do seven note perfect a Baba Baba
lore friendly mode I love lore we
doesn't love Laura I love lore you love
lore we love you lord i love the lore of
that i'm actually been reading a lot of
SCP articles lately i think i might have
mentioned that but i don't know if I
mentioned that in an SCP video whoo
ha ha everything looks like a sack of
potatoes slapped around in a bar Nuri I
think I think oh man I my graphic
settings are low potato potato
graphics level Ultra Plus Ultra all
right ah ain't that better is that
better usually sometimes with these
things you have to restart the game to
actually get it to go
let me just do that just in case let's
wake up again
ooh that's a good-looking suit right
there now we're in it now this is better
all I'm immersed my immersion yes
finally Wow
[Music]
hello oh there we go now we're looking
good
now we're looking good why is the futile
view so high you know I want this to
feel cramped oh yeah
no it's too great to area that feels
good that feels cramped whoa you're dead
and I'm not out how long will that stay
the same way I know not for I'm a stupid
a-hole who no need to mom mr.
alarm so I imagine there's not gonna be
too much different in terms of the
initial experience I think it's just
about the same those good rented
coordinators
how many do I hate STP 3,000 SCP 3000 is
my ultimate nightmare last doors
and they really got to make that faster
oh yeah dad it's team to the food man
the improvements in this one it's just
nuts so it looks like there's a bit more
detail here but you know whatever it's
Yatta Yatta Yatta Yatta Yatta you buddy
let me get a slug of water and let's get
out of here it's time to go baby go I
don't know if there was a key card up
there I've completely forgotten there's
what happens every time I get back into
one of these games and there's an update
and spend this long I forget everything
about it I forget everything that
happened and I have no idea what was
going on ever forever and ever
all right those thighs doh but that baby
head in those sticker it's a horrible
snowman oh they changed 173
I don't think Billy's Billy no more I
got bandaged I got two bandages I got
three bandages I see into the Sun pain
okay well this is new I see I see skies
blue clouds white something something
I'm gonna die it's really a depressing
song if you listen to the lyrics closely
and for some reason I can't open that
gap I remember that from before it
doesn't make a lot of sense but I will
ignore it okay so the reason I'm
hesitant is because I don't know when
there's gonna be something coming after
me oh my God look at that it's got signs
tells me what's going on over here
now what was six five zero ooh here's
our gonna test our memory and see if we
get asked
well the blinks have begun my Blanc errs
have engaged my self-defense
Blanco's all right we're just gonna
Blanc our way over this way well that's
new Billy I don't like new Billy knew
Billy sucks cool good thank you
new Billy new blue new blonde Oh bleep
where the hell am I
where the Frick frack am i whoo oh good
a side hallway perfect for running I
love running Wow
sparks so pretty look at the lighting on
that a thing of beauty
why am I here what am i doing what am i
doing with my life other than trying to
save it I didn't see what was in there
what was in there I didn't see what was
in there what was in there well am i
Blancos engaged just because Blanco
Billy was in there otherwise known as
Blanco Billy oh yeah yeah I'm sure
[Music]
shoot me it's all I ask
shoot me just shoot me all right
whatever we're gonna have to brave this
you're gonna take a look at what this
thing is where are you well I don't see
you I'm gonna blink I'm gonna blink I'm
gonna do it I want to show you so why is
my blinked Amador engaged when nothing's
blink Blanc and I hate it I don't know
what's happening I think I'm gonna die
I'm gonna die I'm gonna die pick save
yes whoo
[Music]
why am I here Oh what's in here well I'm
a bling blong good whoa what's with the
blinky blonde keys why am i blinking a
ting I don't like the idea that you dad
asked Oh
oh hey hey hi guys it's me
markiplier you know none of those are my
hoobs all right um Wow hey bud how you
doing good to cease use you haven't been
skipping leg day I see that I see that
with both of my eyes but arm day you
need to work on your bicep curls I hate
you I hate that so much worse I don't
mean like worse like it looks worse it I
mean it looks worse but it'll like you
you actually seem hazard just know other
than the other one the other version it
seemed like it wanted to give me a hug
okay so I think the answer is I'm never
going in there oh why would I ever go in
there dry pod new bill he sucks alright
okay hello good never mind I don't want
it I don't want it I don't want it oh
god oh god god no no okay
what I have to do what I gotta do is I
gotta open the door and I get a lead it
out and then go in the other door and
then close it before it can kill me
alright everyone on the same page here
here we go just gonna blink and then
we're gonna do this okay hey bud hey bud
hey bud hey bud hey bud Hibbert Hibbert
Hibbert
[Music]
just gonna curl up in a blanket here
that did not work out as planned I did
not work out as planned at all that went
the opposite as bland alright well
there's gonna be a problem
I'm only assuming that it's guarding
something oh boy oh boy I hate this so
much
alright so oh is it gone it'll like
despawn or something
I say it's gone I think it's gone okay I
think it's gone sure sure sure sure sure
sure sure sure sure sure sure
complete GI bakes approved Docs ah I
don't speak French I know not of what
you mean are you up there or are you not
up here okay you're not up here oh hi
how you doing
Oh Pio so cute and there's a crow BRR
can I take that can I want something
please tell me I have something with
which to defend myself
sure would be bad if I didn't was there
nothing up here a certain ol reason to
come up here even need to go up here
that's great that's great it's a lot of
nothing oh the core you say I love me a
core what do we do with the core do I
need to turn it on to power up the thing
I remember in the other version there
was something like that but I don't know
if this one's also going to have it Oh
gruesome string of murders reaches its
end gotcha
is that radical Larry alright cool I
mean you know I think that might go into
the core I'm gonna see what this is all
about okay yeah the core is everywhere
SCP 131 176 to
staff offices sublevel okay I can only
assume that it is in fact important to
actually activate the core because why
would they build this fancy big area if
it wasn't some kind of important I can
only assume that it is in fact important
well this isn't very useful
what does anybody get to do with this no
there's not even a desk set up there
helps nobody this is scp-914 one four
nine nine and sl2 a nine one four is
that the clockwork machine Oh SCP 505 I
don't know if 505 is but it don't look
good it's gonna pretend like I didn't
see it sometimes with these things even
knowing about it is deadly so I'm gonna
forget oh my goodness very dramatic yeah
a
why is there seating who's gonna sit
here in the huge radioactive core hey
maybe I had the perfect date for us
we're gonna go to the core my ass seems
super safe this is safe this is what I
call safe hey can I get out this way can
I use this to get out like go away you
know why don't I go to sublevel 3 I know
you're dead Oh someone walked here but
that makes little sense why would there
why would they have blood footprints
here walking towards that unless you
walked over there to die ah this is you
right the answer was obvious the whole
time the killer was in the room the
whole time down in the old dusty trail
machine hallway sl3
secure storage sl3
eh all right oh loading a new cluster I
didn't even finish the other cluster one
hour later ah
peek-a-boo I see you
actually I don't see you that's more
worrisome is that stars or is it my own
oh no that's dust
I thought those stars outside of a
window I'm just stupid
I realize this now I'm actually an idiot
not even pretended it I'm just really
dumb ok good this looks industrial it's
the only descriptor that I can come up
with too
Wow Wow secure storage and machine
hallway I don't know what a machine
hallway is I don't know why you would
call something a machine Hall it sounds
deadly I'm imagining knives pointing and
slicing from the walls
all right let's go let's see what the
though machine Wow
I didn't want it get away from this
stuff
I will not shake your hand social
distancing all right my first warning
was that I couldn't save Wow
that is horrifying all right where oh no
no no oh no the car the car of course
the gore all right this time before we
go dude into the other level of the core
let's make sure that we've got
everything that we need in this this
level of the Cure hi okay good save I'm
not gonna save too often because it
feels cheating I don't like it ha this
looks exactly the same as the previous
thing that I found SCP 131 and 176 - I
don't remember what scp-172 62 is and
for some reason I don't even remember
what one three three one was well we're
about to find out that's what this game
is all about right going to going
towards the monsters ah I remember you
you're a bastard
[Music]
my instinct of the timing from the
previous attempts that that have failed
me it used to be a mama where long face
well why the long face all right take
two following the disastrous security
event last August the administration of
site 48 has decided to update the
facility's security protocol accordingly
okay what what what what whoa no hey
whoa whoa whoa I'm going you can't pass
you can't pass fastest Abbas Abbas ah I
was reading why am I not running Oh God
God why couldn't I run I was in the
sludge 106 didn't kill me I could kill
by a gate
mr. radical I was reading the busy you
big dick you big floppy p-norm
okay secure the office sublevel one okay
so there is a sublevel if this is the
Security office I should be may be able
to get something from in there okay so
my first mission has gotta be to get a
security card
oh it's where what's happening what's
happening we're going on hey what's the
dealio this one's a fun one this one's
nice
it's okay I don't have any argon that's
all right 9:1 forest downstairs so I'm
already kind of screwed about that
whatever it's fine I'm fine thanks for
asking I'm fine I'm not a good idea to
leave all these doors open
I should probably definitely act closing
behind me where am I headed again I
don't even remember where I'm heading Oh
oh I'm sorry oh I'm very soon
okay what the hell are you nice carpet I
remember after that as a kid or at least
is that like my high school or something
what are you after careful evaluation of
your application of dual assignment a
senior security and of your performances
acting security of at omnis entities we
are happy to inform you that you have
been confirmed for the position you will
report directly to lieutenant reeves
commencing with your activation on nine
eighteen twenty blue tomorrow report of
the security office one at 6:00 a.m. to
begin your assignment when your shift
ends you'll proceed to containment to
your seat - for the rest of your day
please note that you will be assigned a
locker in the Security office store your
personal effects okay that doesn't tell
me anything about those things that does
that mean that his key to get into that
office is in here somewhere because if
it is I have my ticket in bondage
bondage thank you Oh horrible horrible
horrible horrible horrible
on three one A and one three one beer a
pair of teardrop shaped creatures
roughly thirty centimeters in height
with a single blue eye in the middle of
their bodies at the base of each
creature is a wheel like protrusion
which allows for locomotion suggesting
the creature may be biomechanical in
origin the subject possesses the
intelligence of common houses cats
although curious the subjects can sense
danger in their general vicinity and if
a person begins purging them with
something they register is dangerous
that will swarm around the person's feet
while babbling in a panicked tone as if
to warn them during an incident that
took place on bla the subject following
one of the cleaning staff on a routine
cleaning of the chamber once inside the
staff members observe the subject
sitting in front of scp-173 and watching
it intently as if aware that it could
only move if unobserved interesting the
cleaners ignore the presence of the
subjects and continued with the
bi-weekly cleaning as per standard
procedures when the cleaning crew left
the subject is as well rolling backwards
slowly and never taking their eyes off
scp-173 current applications oh well
that's very handy although I hate the
way they look here it looks like lips
are on tonight
it's no good no bueno no way oh wait
wait wait a minute wait wait wait are
you telling me are you telling me that
are you telling me that if I get these
things out of there I'm going to be able
to use them to keep an eye on 173 so
that I can move that means if I can get
173 in this room they will be properly
condemned that sounds pretty good that
sounds pretty good all right I don't
have anything I need to get a card yet
okay all right how far is this range on
your walking don't kill me don't kill me
that's too close I don't like it I don't
like it don't like it I like it none I
hate you actually I actually don't like
you what do you look like a plus what
are you even
I shouldn't tempt fate I shouldn't have
a fade but here I am tempting fate
hello oh look at you is so pathetic
Oh God okay okay never mind I thought
that would have been farther away on the
jump all right that's cool bro that's
cool cool good yeah great actually you
know what I mean
anyway see Ron kids see Ron it's good
dug into you so we got it I mean I don't
even know what we got to do now we got
to figure out a way to get in here
eventually oh it's like an intercom so
it's like an intercom which means that
if I can get like a oh I thought that
was open for a second okay I can get
that maybe there's something unlike the
the office wait this is sublevel two ooh
wait a minute okay so for in sublevel
two that means that sublevel one must be
where oh yeah oh yeah yeah oh no low
oxygen levels detected I don't remember
any windows warning telling me about low
oxygen levels but okay
hi you look so happy anyway you're all
dead now I don't know if there's
anything of use in any of these places
so there really wasn't a point to come
down here that's what I'm discovered
oh my freaking God I didn't even find us
where was his EP once 1 3 1
no that was this where's 1 7 6 - I don't
even know I don't even know I don't even
know I need to get to sublevel one so
can I take the central elevator up
because if I can take it up then if I'm
on sublevel - it's the only thing I can
imagine right
oh no wait here was nine one oh wait it
was the place with the argon chamber of
course I'm dumb I'm big big big dumb
loading new pluster okay hello why was
it so slappy what was slappy something
was slappy I didn't like the slaps
something slip slapped I know some slip
slapped I don't like the slippy Slappy's
or the slippy slap he's ain't good I'm
one four okay nine one four is good
everyone loves nine one four we love
nine one four I love nine one four he
see me love nine one four there she is
there she is my good lad I don't know if
there's a supreme woo I don't know if
there's a supreme benefit to getting the
argon for the thing to do the thing that
does the thing but you know maybe
alright
empty h2o fill it with h2o one object at
a time right I've done this part before
I don't know if I need to do this part
again I'm not 100% sure if everything
here is perfectly fine oh yeah I read
this before I'm not amazed by it anymore
I'm grateful but
not amaz'd also I can't put that song in
it kids copyright is that song it's
super copyright Oh interesting
oh ye H to some type of explosive liquid
h e gas with very low density do not
inhale wait right there that's a card
can I have that oh come on it looks like
a card that I can have why would they
put that there if I couldn't actually
use it oh that's dumb
alright whatever alright cool so I need
argon so I need to get to nitrogen to n2
so h2 + o on fine equals n2 right I got
it I got I forgot I can't jump I was
gonna jump down ooh what's this oxygen
my inventory is flaw I didn't even know
I had an inventory Oh bandages that's
right I'm full up on bandages I guess we
just drop some of these you don't need
this money yeah that's plenty
ok h2 plus oxygen that's what we need to
do we're just gonna get the argon ok
I've got two helium and two oxygen so I
need to put helium together to make this
work
neon then two neons gonna make an argon
that's right okay we got two neons we're
gonna make an air organ
all right I got the organ I did it I'm
the best what would happen if I put a
alright experiment time what happens if
I put a bandage then turn it to very
fine or fine let's make it so a fine
bandage
a nice fine bandage give it a bandage
give it a bandage ooh large bandage
large eh
all right what about very fine huh an
explosive bandage a living bandage a
large bandage now right
that's underwhelming what about a large
bandage what's that gonna turn into kind
of horrible monstrosity could this
possible create ooh a medical hype oh oh
oh sure cool I'm down for this you know
it turned down for what what about two
bandages Oh medium scrap I have some
nice scrap that's cool medium scrap -
what happens if I put the medium scrap
in small scrap oh that wasn't what I
expected
all right small scrap butter in
boo is boring alright I'm gonna I'm
gonna make this in here here we go you
ready nailed it
Oh
I'm alive did it do anything
yes put me through how really doesn't
like me really does not want to do
anything to me I'm just gonna load just
in case it like horribly destroyed me
okay that's enough messing around with
that alright actually I'm gonna end this
episode here because unfortunately no
time thank you everybody so much for
watching look forward to more content
coming at you from the newest update of
SCP unity lot of cool stuff what do you
think of the new design of Millie you
think radical areas just as much of a
douche as ever before let me know in the
comments and check out some of the other
SCP videos that I've made linked in the
description or in the suggested videos
down there thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]